do you ever feel like you're being
watched not by a creepy stalker but by
aliens well it might be happening just
like we watch animals at the zoo aliens
may be out there watching us like we're
the zoo animals but why exactly would
they be doing this in the first place
could they be afraid of us this is what
if and here's what would happen if we
lived in a galactic Zoo imagine being
trapped in a zoo
well if we really do live in a galactic
Zoo then you'd already be in one a lien
could be out there watching your every
move they may want to study the human
race or learn from our technology or
maybe they're planning to attack us but
what if instead of attacking us the
aliens are afraid of us attacking them
wait what if you've watched any sort of
sci-fi movie you may think of aliens as
the bad guys the ones who attack our
planet and steal all our resources Hey
shoo get out of there get away get go
but never mind humans being afraid of
aliens they may be afraid of us think
about it it's entirely possible that
aliens have been watching earth since
the birth of humanity if aliens have
been hanging around since the beginning
think of all the horrible destruction
they've seen humans cause deforestation
pollution and let's not forget about war
lots of war humans are constantly trying
to kill each other it's estimated that
almost 1 billion people have died from
war throughout history so from the
aliens perspective humans might seem
like an incredibly violent scary species
they may not want to make contact
because they're afraid of how we might
react which could very well be with
violence and while aliens might be
watching us we aren't confined to a zoo
we have left the earth and gone to the
moon but are we sure that intelligent
life is even out there well the odds are
pretty good the existence of alien life
could be explained by the Fermi paradox
we have our Sun but in the universe
there are billions of other Suns and
they're billions of years older than our
solar system orbiting these other Suns
could be earth-like planets and on
earth-like planets there's a good chance
of there being highly intelligent life
with so many worlds out there there's an
even better chance that at least one of
them has developed interstellar travel
the Fermi paradox suggests that with
interstellar travel it would take a few
million years to travel through the
entire Milky Way galaxy you may think
that sounds like an incredibly long time
but if there's a civilization that is
billions of years older than us it would
just be a tiny fraction of their history
so if all this is true which is very
likely the aliens may have already found
us and apart from us being a pretty
violent species we may not be
interesting enough for them to make
contact with us we may just be another
life-form out of the thousands or
millions that the aliens have seen after
all if you see an ant colony on the
ground do you try to make contact with
it you most likely go along with your
day to other life-forms out there we may
just be a simple group of ants ants they
don't want to hurt or bother just
observe another thing we have to keep in
mind is how we communicate with the
aliens ants in our world might be trying
to communicate with us but unless they
send the right signals we'll never know
the same goes for the aliens and us we
may not be communicating with the aliens
the right way they may not even know
that we want to make contact with them
so they just leave us alone
what is the best way to communicate with
aliens we'll leave that story for
another what-if
[Music]